thank you
okay good evening
again good evening everybody and welcome
to tonight's planning committee meeting
my name is peter richards and i will be
chairing tonight's meeting um some
housekeeping start with by may we're not
expecting a fire alarm but if we do have
one please follow all of us out to the
main car park and we will just make sure
that everyone is out of the building
safe and well mobile phones if you could
please turn those to silence at the very
least off would be preferable um i don't
mind if you want to use them just as
long as they don't disrupt the process
of this meeting um just to remind
everyone we are being live streamed to
youtube and we are being recorded for
later viewing either through our website
or again on youtube so just please be
aware of that
some introductions uh to start us off
with them so to my far right we have
caroline nash committee services to my
immediate right is ross chambers our
solicitor and our planning officers are
eddie wrench joe brooke and aaron
weatherston and to my immediate left is
dale barker who is our planning manager
dave i believe you have a statement to
make
thank you yes my role tonight is to
provide impartial advice and to assist
members in their decision-making thank
you chair thank you very much let's get
into the first item of the meeting which
is apologies for absence caroline do we
have any apologies chairman apologies
received from councillor adam curtis and
mills
thank you very much and disclosures of
interest as next item members um i'll
kick us off if i may on the first
application 2101195
out um we have had or i certainly have
had um a correspondence from the
developer and i've also had some further
correspondence with an objection from
the parish council i believe that was
sent to you all if i could have a thumbs
up just to confirm
yep sort of a blanket disclosure on that
does anyone else have any other
disclosures counselor foreman yes could
i uh register
i click
sorry item number seven i'm on austin
town council and i'm on the planning
committee so i will withdraw for that
item
okay lovely thank you anyone else with
any disclosures at this point
no jolly good okay um our next item is
the minutes can everyone please confirm
they're happy with the minutes and i can
sign those after the meeting a quick
thumbs up would do a unanimous thumbs up
marvelous in that case let's get on with
our first application which is
application
2101195 out that's land north of
miller's close in welfare on avenue our
presenting officer is ellie wren eddie
whenever you're ready
thank you chair
uh this is an outline application for
the construction of up to 10 self-built
custom build dwellings alterations to
access and laying out a public open
space
approval sort for access at this outline
stage
the application site is located within
the village of welford.navon as denoted
here by the black dot
the site currently houses a large
greenhouse is accessed from mila's close
to the south and abuts the welfare
conservation area to the west as shown
here by the dotted pink line
the nearest list property is crest
farmhouse to the southwest which is a
grade two listed
and is shown here in red
this is the plot layout for the ten
dwellings the northern boundary would
sit outside individual ownership and
would be separately managed to ensure a
strong green boundary to the fields
beyond
is reinforced and maintained
this is the proposed parameters plan
which along with the design code sets
the concepts and requirements for
potential future reserve matters
applications
shown here are the build areas where any
development would need to sit
as well as front and rear building lines
in addition to this the design code
would restrict the dwellings to two
stories with pitchers up to a ridge
height of nine meters
as well as a set of materials which are
drawn from the surrounding village
this is this along with the plot layout
would be conditioned as part of any
potential permission
this plan is an indicative layout with
dwellings shown that would conform to
the design code and parameters plan
each dwelling however would be subject
to reserve matters submissions for
appearance scale layout and landscaping
if it was forthcoming
as part of the proposals
there would be alterations to the access
to the site this plan is of the proposed
highways alterations which includes a
realignment of miller's close as well as
new pedestrian footpaths from the site
which would lead to the existing
footpath link to the high street
shown at the bottom of the plan
the existing highways alignment is shown
here in blue
and just to confirm the existing
footpath link to the high street is
shown here on the
lower part portion of the plan
this is a view from within the site
towards the existing greenhouse
this is another photo from within the
site and the northern boundary showing
the existing vegetation
this is looking from the site back
towards the rear elevations of the
properties along miller's close
and this one is
from the site access towards fraser's
way which is directly across
um
high street pedestrian link
is just through here
this is a long mill as close with the
application site on the left hand side
you can just about see the green houses
through the gap
this is one closer to the existing and
proposed access just looking eastwardly
along miller's close
and this one's just further outside from
the welford high street looking towards
the junction with miller's close
and with the site just off to the left
and there is just a short video
if you
uh this is from within the site so those
are the green houses with the eastern
boundary trees a small coppice
and then the rear of the houses along
miller's close from within the site
just pulling around to the
existing and proposed access which would
just be off to the north
now this is from the site access so the
high street was just there on the right
hand side moving towards fraser's way
and just panning around to where the
proposed access would be and looking
eastwardly along miller's close
and just panning around scope so there's
the existing field gate into the site
and again the high street with the
listed building
just shown there in the
center left of the picture
updates include a further condition from
wcc ecology details of the members site
visit
and updates from
planning policy
chair the recommendation is to grant
outline permission subject to a section
106 agreement and to the conditions
outlined on page 24 of the agenda as
well as the additional condition from
wcc ecology thank you
eddie thank you very much we'll move to
our first speaker who is councillor
simon carter from welford parish council
good evening and welcome
we've seen a lot of you so i think you
know the drill
three minutes it's the middle button um
once you're done if you wouldn't mind
please wiping the table down with one of
the cloths in front of you and then
antibacking your hands there's a bin
just to your left where you can chuckle
in as well so otherwise three minutes
it's over to you
and the song
that's it
good evening councillors um we
understand the need to provide
self-built custom uh homes but they
don't have to be outside the built-up
area boundary in a village that's
already had 194 houses versus its
allocation of 84. the sap even
recognizes this and has put welford in
tier 7 at the bottom of the list of more
houses
they could be built actually on two
developments in the village western
house or kelsteen so there are
alternatives if they were chosen to be
explored
there are many reasons to refuse this
application as we've detailed in our in
our response
but last year councillors assured
everybody that the sap would only be
needed if sdc falls short of its
five-year land supply so don't worry
about it in addition statements were
also made telling developers not to put
in any spurious applications on sites
included in the sap because they won't
be accepted
as of today sdc has an 8.4 year land
supply well above the sap trigger point
so why is it that officers are accepting
new houses identified in the sap and
outside the built-up barrier boundary
we really feel as though we've been
seriously let down on this uh on this
matter if you need reasons to refuse
this application please look at our
detailed summary but in summary the sap
isn't planning policy it doesn't
supersede the core strategy that's
actually a statement i've had from the
head of planning the sap should not be
given such waiters to override the core
strategy and a made neighborhood plan
which is what welford has there is still
inaccuracies in the schla if you go and
have a look at the schla you will see
that this land is actually grade two
listed therefore it's red according to
rules that means there's four reds
actually for this site which means it's
undeliverable
highways is a significant issue um for
both traffic pedestrians and children um
we would ask why warranty county
councils have changed their mind about
the access issues and said this
development is okay now
there are already 15 houses within this
sort of confined area of chapel street
and miller's close
um this 10 would make it up to 25.
that's actually a very similar number
that warwickshire county council
rejected last time when an application
came in
the appeal inspector also supported that
and rejected it on the basis that
actually there were too many houses in
this area
with regards to the footpath um we know
that footpath is never used we live
there we just know that nobody goes down
there they all walk through the gap
which is single file from miller's close
onto the high street that's the way the
kids go the cyclists go the elderly go
everybody goes that way
this development is on the edge of the
conservation area and we find it quite
interesting that you know crest farm is
at the entrance to this development um
the assessment here by the officers is
that this doesn't do any damage uh to
the conservation area i certainly can't
see how it enhances it
welfare naval neighbor uh housing needs
survey was done in 19 2019 may 2019 that
didn't identify any need for self-built
houses in welford i'm gonna have to
actually wrap it up now if i mean that's
a more up-to-date uh document than any
of the other planning things and that
does carry real weight please refuse
this application
thank you thank you very much members do
we have any questions for councillor
carter please
council crump
yeah just uh kenneth carter just good
evening just touching on that point
about self builds um
honestly you briefly mentioned in the
housing plan um assessment that there
wasn't any need identified was there
anything identified in your
neighborhood plan for
no our neighbourhood plan started
development before it's a bit like the
core strategy i mean our neighborhood
plan actually went live in
2017 in june
but of course actually the government
regulation only came in in 15 and we'd
already started that and sdc actually
didn't have any policy for self-build
you could well argue though in welford
that we've had quite a number of
self-built i could point to at least six
houses that have been done by
individuals as a self-build opportunity
so
on that basis i mean 10 actually is a
very large development for self-build
it's larger than any of the normal
proposals and we've already had i can
point to six of them that have been done
on this you know on this basis so we've
really met that criteria already
thank you councillor carter
answered some questions i didn't even
ask there so thank you very much
thank you for the opportunity
anyone else with any questions
no in that case council cartel thank you
very much if you thank you very much
quickly wipe down the desk and then and
pack your hands that'd be great
and while you're doing that i will call
forward our next speaker who is liz
nicholson our agent for the application
thanks very much thank you
as i think you know the drill as well
three minutes 30 second warning and
whenever you're ready it's over to you
we recognize that this is the first of
the self-built custom house bill sites
identified in the draft site allocation
as planned to come to your committee
and with that in mind roscon strategic
land and stansgate have worked hard with
your officers to design a high quality
scheme and associated design code that
meet all policy requirements and address
all technical points raised by
consultees
we have valued the positive attitude and
focused advice that we've received from
eddie wrench and paul harris
particularly with regards to the draft
legal agreement which will control the
future marketing and occupancy of each
plot
we also recognize the difficulty that
the council is currently in when the
legislation on self-built custom house
bill plots came into effect the court
strategy was at such an advanced stage
it was not possible to take that
legislation into account
so the council has been left without a
policy to guide decision making on this
type of housing
the council has a legal duty to provide
enough plots to meet demand and this is
a duty that it is currently failing to
meet
it is therefore left in a position where
that legal duty is either going to be
met through applications being allowed
on appeal possibly through schemes that
the council would have preferred to
resist
all the legal duty needs to be met by
the council approving schemes on
suitable sites in appropriate locations
as identified in its draft site
allocations plan
in other words even though the core
strategy is silent the council has an
opportunity to control development to
meet its expectations
there was a previous application on this
site for 30 open market dwellings in
2014
which was dismissed on appeal on the
grounds of highways and character of the
area
i'm sure you'll agree with your officers
that a low density scheme of just 10
dwellings would be consistent with the
existing character of the area
and since that appeal decision a
classified turning count and a road
safety audit have been carried out as
well as pre-application discussions with
county council highways officers
the county highways authority now has no
objection to these proposals
drainage has been a key local concern
but a flood risk assessment and drainage
strategy has been submitted with the
application and the lead local flood
authority has no objection to the
proposals
a heritage statement has been submitted
with the application which concludes
that there is no harm to heritage assets
from the proposed development which is
the same conclusion that the appeal
inspector reached in 2014 when
considering the previous 30 dwelling
scheme
even if the council concludes that there
is a small degree of harm caused in
accordance with paragraph 202 of the
framework
such harm is clearly outweighed by the
public benefits this site would deliver
by making a meaningful contribution to
the council's legal responsibilities to
provide sufficient service plots for
this type of housing need on a site
which is allocated in the draft site
allocations plan 30 seconds
i can confirm as well that any
biodiversity offsetting contribution
would be provided locally at allscott
in conclusion there are no technical
grounds on which to refuse this
application and we would ask that the
development is supported
marvelous thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions for our
agent please
cancel dixon
thank you chairman liz um
obviously uh we're about advised here
that a minimum achievement of 31
reduction in carbon emissions is within
the report is there any possibility that
that could be increased by your eight by
your applicants and the if we are
minded to grant permission
um i think we'd be reluctant to
take a condition that seeks that level
um because in every other regard this
scheme is delivering what you ask for
and the 31 is obviously what you've
proposed in in the draft sap i think if
you're seeking something higher than
that it maybe needs to come through your
revised policies um but there's a
condition there to look at renewables
and and
carbon reduction and we could look at
achieving what we could through that
any other questions members
no in that case liz thank you very much
for your contribution
while you clean the desk i shall call
forward on next week here is cancer per
together
good evening councillor welcome good
evening
you'll have five minutes we'll give you
a 30 second warning otherwise whenever
you're ready it's over to you
thank you
good evening members
the proposed site is outside the
build-up area boundary in fact the site
is both rural employment site best
agricultural land in one of the few
remaining open countryside settings of
our village
the proposals are in conflict with
policy core strategy 15 distribution of
development which states the villages
that in villages any development will
only take place on sites identified in
the neighborhood development plan or
through small schemes on suitable sites
within the build-up area boundary
the site is bounded by by edge rows and
fields he also bounds the conservation
area and his adjacent to a great list
building the proposed development on
this site will impact on the character
and setting of the conservation area
with the urbanization of a rural setting
the proposal is contrary to policy he
five open countryside or the welford
neighborhood development plan
the intrinsic character and beauty of
the open countryside lying outside the
village build-up area should be
preserved development will only be
supported in exceptional circumstances
and none of these apply here the
proposal is contrary to policy core
strategy 16 and policy hlu1 housing
development of the neighborhood
development plan
well for the scene a large increase in
development more than doubling the
required 84 hours to 2031 they've been
194 properties approved
the site allocation plan is not a made
document therefore any planning
application on this side is premature
and if committee members are asked to
consider the site allocation plan then
they would also need to consider the
welford has been put in tier seven for a
list of sites tier seven is for those
villages that ever accommodated
significant housing and therefore
these would be the last sites to be
released
as per july 21 in the self build
register there are only three applicants
specifically requesting a plot in
welfare and members self-pit plots are
usually single dwelling plots
so
as they should be because these are
exempt from paying a community
infrastructure levy or delivering
affordable housing if granted this would
be the largest self-built scheme in the
district without the developers having
to contribute to infrastructure or meet
our local housing needs
and these are self big plots the
tranquil setting will be disrupted for
years to come with construction traffic
noise dust and pollution as each plot is
developed individually and on its own
time scale
the same council reviews the previous
application on this site and
successfully defended its appeal because
of the unacceptable adverse impact on
the highway safety caused by and i quote
the substandard access visibility is
placed to the east which are hampered by
number eight existing boundary fans and
brick gate pillars on the west there is
the pinch point at the junction between
miller's close and the high street where
the road narrows to a single carriageway
we restricted with the inspector
recognized that any development here
would contribute to increased queuing
and delay on the iowa network with the
potential to leak to increase accidents
in the vicinity of the junction highway
objected on the previous application on
the grounds of access and impact on
junction recognize that the development
will increase the intensification of
this route increasing the potential for
accidents to correct this location the
pinch point is still there the brick
pillars are still there if anything the
traffic has increased as the village
expanded and more vehicles through the
high street with the new development in
longmarston and me unveil the proposed
pedestrian connectivity through
fraserway was already heavily criticized
by the previous planning officer who
found the alternative route to be less
attractive to persons from the
development due to being more distant
and convoluted this the tour cannot be
used by cyclists anyway we still have to
use the dangerous pinch point
crops are grown directly in the ground
because of the of its excellent
productive soil i understand this
agricultural land is great too
best agricultural land enjoys protection
in our mppf and in our core strategy any
development who removed this land from
food production it is of national
interest to protect the best versatile
agricultural land
among the welfare plan objectives to
2031 adopted by this council we have
that the rural nature of the parish with
open countryside setting in green
environment will have been preserved
any development will minimize commuting
and traffic movements
these self-built proposals work against
these objectives and do not constitute
sustainable development i urge the
committee to refuse this application
thank you
council thank you very much members do
we have any questions for cancer
personality counselor dixon
um you i asked the uh the agent um
whether or not uh uh 100 or passive
house might be possible
if it were possible would that change
your opposition to this application and
before you answer that one um seeing the
site um i think i read in here that
there weren't many employees there is
there a business currently operating
from that glass house and if so
um or if not how long has it been
redundant
well
i mean we were on site in fact so now on
monday and there are uh you know there's
lettuce i think we we thought uh growing
uh through the greenhouses so i think i
understand there is an agricultural
business operating there
um and you know these crops uh someone
has to come and pick them up and um you
know grow them so i'm assuming there is
a business
and my my problem is the the the
self-built the this is a huge uh
self-built plot and the impact uh you
know of obviously in an ideal world you
know possible yes i would like to see
all new development festivals is all new
development but this will impact on on
on on the open countryside i mean this
site is not within the build-up area and
you know the the people of welford have
voted for their build-up area which this
council has adopted so and no i won't
change my mind
we can perhaps pick up the business
thing in there in our clarification with
the officer anyone else have any
questions for cancer personally
no
oh cancer hence therapy okay
um
can you give us some idea how many
houses were allocated to welford and how
many have actually been built so in the
core strategy i think um if our policy
uh core strategy 15 or 16 i can remember
now but it was 84. so uh well
with the um percentage or strategy we
would have to have 84. and from our
data uh we have been we reach now 194 uh
properties that have been given uh they
go ahead to be built
and i think um i did prepare the
presentation where you could see
which ones were in the build up area
which one outside but my presentation
was too late so
but yeah
so i mean we more than doubled our we
did our right yeah i hope you answered
the question now all right don't have
any more
any other one any other questions you
can suppose together
no in that case counselor thank you very
much for your contribution
we will now move to points clarification
to our offices i think we've already got
one um do we know
if there is an active business on the
site and if there is how long it's been
active how long it will be active please
thank you chair uh there is an active
business on the site they currently grow
i think it's salad leaves
eddie can we leave it at that there's a
business on site yeah there is yeah
okay i don't think that's helped much um
while he's trying to find that why don't
we have a few more points for
clarification does anyone else have
anything they would like to raise
councillor crump yeah thank you mr
chairman um
it's just in the conclusion on page 24
um which says that uh existence of
national policy and guidance on honest
matters should be a material
consideration weighing heavily in five
of the granting of planning permission
for such schemes in appropriate
locations
i assume we would have to take into
account the planning balance whether
building outside the built-up area
boundary is an appropriate location
what is that is that fair
chair we have um paul harris with us
from our policy team tonight um
virtually
and i think he's probably the best man
to answer that question paul did you
receive the did you hear the question
thanks julia i i heard the question i
hope you can hear my answer because i
was struggling with the technology
earlier so can you hear me we can hear
you fine johnny good
yeah i think uh councillor crump
and the committee as a whole need needs
to very much bear in mind that
yeah we have a core strategy
and we have a made ndp
but in both cases the uh
the prerequisite of the
self-building custom house building act
of 2015 and its accompanying regulations
really does
require local authorities to to look at
providing specifically for this form of
housing which really
it was on the horizon but when we
produced our respective plans
there was no opportunity to make policy
provision
for self-filled specifically or to
allocate sites specifically for
self-build
so the reality is in in a place like
welford you have a built up area
boundary where infilling and small scale
developments and replacement dwellings
are
are
acceptable in in terms of policy
principle but there is no or very
limited scope to provide
sites of this nature and
the sap has it will be seeking to fill
that void
but at the moment it can it can be given
limited weight
but
besides that the the requirements of the
act really need to take effect and that
that's the expectation of national
policy
and local policy is silent on on how we
do that so
it is important that we
we recognize that the national act
does have to take effect and we can't
wait for the sap to be produced to give
us that lead
paul just if i made from that
am i writing saying that uh what you've
just said is that because the core
strategy is silent on custom build
and we have a national policy the
national policy takes precedence over
the course strategy is that a fair
assessment
it is very much and the mppf that makes
that very clear
okay thank you council crump
to follow up again on that um
i noticed on the update sheet
173 self-build permissions with 225
entries on the register
so bear with me on this paul
when people put an entry on the register
do they specify they want to build a
self build in a certain location or is
it just a self build a general self
build
and therefore by putting 10 in this
location
are we able to satisfy that 52 we're
short of on the list because they
the
52 and they might all want to be built
in southern for example yeah just just
that's my key point there
there is a question on the uh
the form whereby people submit their
interest in being on the register which
does ask
where their preferable location would be
to build their own house but that that
is just
i mean that doesn't necessarily mean
that
that's the only place they build a house
it's just an opportunity to say where
their preferred location is many
many don't specify a particular
settlement they might say
you know the traffic area or the
southern area or the shipston area
some do
make a specific location
there's the opportunity to do that
but i think the important thing to
recall to remember is that the
self-build register is a district-wide
register
it's an indicator of the level of
interest in building your own house
in the district but it's not necessarily
the sum total of everybody out there who
would be interested if they had that
opportunity
and there's certainly no requirement to
match people on the register with the
the availability and location of plots
as i say it's a district-wide register
and
you know if a site like this comes along
should it be approved it's not necessary
for people on the register to be the
only ones that have the opportunity to
purchase a site
we'll wait to see should it get
permission or any sites of this nature
get permission
how the plots are picked up where the
people are from but
the initial requirement is for
purchasers to have a local connection to
the district by way of current residence
current employment or a family
connection to the district as a whole
and not specifically to the settlement
have you got another one cancer cramp
again just a final one
so
if we approve this application
we might end up with still the 225 on
the register
the ones that haven't been
um met
um because they might not think this is
an appropriate location or somebody else
who was thinking about
south build might suddenly come out and
say i want this location so it
it seems quite open-ended i'm just
slightly
uneasy about that
well the gap between demand and supply
would would close
because
you would be providing should this site
get permission an additional 10 plots on
the supply side but the demand side will
stay the same i.e the number of people
on the register that's an indicator and
that's the the national regulations
at the very least expect
the number of plots to be provided to
equate to the number of parties on the
register even though there might be
different people entirely that is the
that the basic
assessment of whether need come demand
is being met
no that's one that's a lot clearer now
i'm misinterpreted to previous answer so
no i'm clear about that now thank you
good stuff anyone else have any
questions points of clarification
if not paul i've while we've got you um
we heard about the sap and welford being
tier seven in terms of uh release of
sites and what have you um can you talk
to me about that um and how that affects
uh this application please
yes see the sap
has a number of intended purposes uh
one and perhaps the main one which is to
identify reserve housing sites which is
a requirement of policy cs16 in the core
strategy
and that's the the overriding purpose
why we're producing a sap but we're also
using it as an opportunity to
put forward and provide a policy on self
build to fill that gap that the core
strategy doesn't deal with and to
identify sites
the
the reference to
the release of reserve sites in various
tiers that we put forward in the
sap at the end of last year that is to
do with reserve sites it's not to do
with self-built sites
the the requirement for self-building is
separate to the requirement for reserve
housing sites
so in a nutshell because this is custom
self bill proposes custom self-built
anyway uh it falls outside of that uh
release of reserve sites and therefore
it's it's not relevant is that right
indeed
okay that's helpful thank you very much
that answers all my questions so if
anyone else has any more questions let's
open up to debate who would like to kick
us off
councillor dixon first
thank you chairman
um to a certain extent i wish these
types of things had been available in
the local authority regime
decades ago
because the one thing that i find
that we always accept essentially
is an awful lot of boxes which all look
awfully similar and i think one of the
advantages of basically having
self builds when they're on a smallish
development of 10 properties
each somewhere close to a quarter of an
acre so they're not small plots
um does give the opportunity i think for
10 individual every single property
different
and from that point of view i am
certainly interested in this one and i
think that's a
a good thing and we need to actually
meet the the government legislation
um it may not have been in time for the
core strategy but say only wish it was
available 20 years ago
is that a proposal to grant or
i would i would make it a proposal but
certainly obviously i think there's
other opinions to be uh gathered around
the moon first there certainly are but
i'll take that as a proposal council
jennings next
thank you sir
a self-building custom house build act
is national legislation
um we need to respond positively to it
there's a shortfall of these
these self-built plots
um
there was a question and it raised
earlier whether there's actually demand
for it well i can tell you self-built
plots are like hens teeth everyone wants
them
um you there'll be a huge demand for
them and when you actually when you do a
self-build it saves you a considerable
amount of money than buying a house
which is already built
or a box
which is built by one of the big
companies
they tend to
generate
advanced building techniques
um and design and that's i believe
that's why passive houses came along
um
and there's been a question about access
here
um
i understand if highways are okay with
it and they're all they are also
widening the access roads here
um
and i said i've listened to all the
arguments but and i understand
that
people don't want to have their lives
disrupted who live down there and it is
and and the passageways etc but
um we need to get the numbers
um
i think the pros outweigh the cons and
i'm happy to propose that we go with the
officer's recommendations
thank you very much council jennings
given we had a
proposal from council dixon i'm going to
take that as a second thing if that's
all right
i think i strong-armed him but yeah
do we have anyone else that wants to
contribute to the debate councillor next
please
thank you chair
um
i kind of agree but disagree uh
i think the scheme is good but i think
councillor pertigella made a good point
in terms of that it's premature for the
site i'm not really very comfortable
with the built-up area boundary piece
and starting to build outside of that if
i'm 100 honest i'm also a bit worried
about it setting a precedent for
everybody jumping all over
various little areas that are just
sitting on the edges of various villages
and towns um
and going itself build name
so i'm not sure i'm gonna
go with
the proposal and the second thing at the
moment
is that a counter proposal just to
clarify
i can absolutely counter propose okay um
while we carry on speaking to everyone
if you come up with your reasons for and
then we'll come back to you um we do
obviously have to take the first
proposal that's been seconded first
council andrew serafin please yeah thank
you chair
um i agree with some of what councillor
edna said
i don't think anybody's taken into
account of the objections the amount of
houses that have already been built in
welford
um
those people do live there and should
have a bit more say i mean it seems as
though
flourish objective 60 objections board
member objected
they must object with good reason
obviously
um
outside of the
built-up boundary
yeah i'm not in favor of granting this
one thank you
just to clarify is that a seconding of
councillor edin
yes
yeah
we will we will get a detailed proposal
shortly
council crump next please
thank you chairman um yeah i'm i'm not
particularly happy about this one but i
think our hands are slightly tied
um obviously we're significantly
overachieving the five-year housing none
supply you know we've got the core
strategy but obviously this came about
or during the course strategy and
and as it appears on page 24 and the
conclusion it seems like the national
legislation is is top trump in the fact
that we've got those five year housing
land supply in the course strategy
so um and with the 20 short for numbers
in terms of entries on the register
compared to permissions
and again
i'm not particularly happy about it and
that's our question sorry the officer um
i was trying to get some understanding
about this
um
and it's almost sometimes like a
self-perpetuating prophecy coming
forward on this so i i do
really struggle with this but i think
if this went to appeal we would lose
most importantly because of page 24
where it says it is considered that the
existence of national policy and
guidance on this matter should be a
material consideration weighing heavily
in favor of granting planning permission
for schemes in appropriate locations and
i tried to ask the officers
about the build
area banji in this being outside the
area of energy and how much weight that
would have
in our of our objection to this and
again
i'll some sort of knock back in a nice
way of course but um i was knocked back
so i'm finding very difficult to support
this but i can't go against it i'm
afraid
thank you counselor counselor fleming
next please
thank you chairman
i've got
two problems with this we're
we're back to building houses on
not exactly prime agricultural land but
it's
agriculture land that provides
employment for people
um we're building houses and villages
and taking away employment opportunities
a bit of a bug bear for me that
um and what we're actually doing is
turning the villages into dormitory or
sleeper villages for the people to go
and work elsewhere
um i can't see
many other reasons to object to it
because i'm in favor of home but itself
builds and whatever else but i'm still
not persuaded to that i would either
support it or refuse it at this
particular stage so i'm just listening
to see what else goes on okay thank you
cancer kendall next please
thank you kendall council foreman next
please thank you chair i've listened to
all the arguments and i'm afraid i have
to agree with uh councillor kendall and
councillor crump i'm not totally
comfortable with it but i think the
council's legal obligation is something
we've got to consider
quite heavily
thank you very much councillor dixon for
one last time uh thank you chairman um
obviously the site is adjacent to the
built-up area boundary it couldn't be
any closer without actually being inside
the built-up area boundary so from that
my point of view i think we could take
some sort of comfort from that it's not
way out into the open countryside away
from everywhere else from that point of
view the other question i would ask of
the officers if i may is is there an
opportunity for a tighter condition
regarding not necessarily passive house
standards but getting higher than we've
got on 31 percent um either by way of
condition or by a way of note
i'm i will refer to our officers i'm
assuming because our policy says 31 then
we're going to be hard-pressed to go
outside of that but i will refer to our
officers and see if they have a view
the policy
indicating that we should achieve 31
is itself not yet an adopted policy
so that policy only carries limited
weight
that policy will also be in line with
the emerging changes to the building
regulations in december and in june next
year
which will be 31
we have no other
policy basis
to require higher energy standards the
applicant isn't offering higher energy
standards
my advice to you is that
you don't have
a
justifiable planning reasons to ask for
greater than 31 percent although
it is possible and actually likely that
self and custom-built people will want
to bring forward higher standards but i
wouldn't give that any weight in your
decision-making because they might not
i think that's the only answer i can
give check
okay thank you very much uh dale okay
unless anyone else has anything else
they want to contribute to the debate at
this point we do have a proposal a
proposal that has been seconded uh so we
will take that first so the proposal is
to grant in line with the officer's
recommendation if we could please have a
show of hands for those in favor
that's five chairmen and those against
sorry chairman that's six
six four hang on a second this is
getting confusing can we show of hands
for four granting
you missed me didn't you
and against please
and abstentions
therefore council committee resolve to
grant application 2101195
out at land at north of miller's close
in welford on haven
okay let's move to our next item which
is application
2101 565 varia land adjacent to holly
bush cottage in prize marston
our presenting officer is joe brooke and
joe as soon as you're settled and able
to get your fits pieces on screen and
you are free to start
business
thank you chair
the site is located in the physical
confines your prize margin as indicated
by the black dot before you
the application is secret permission for
the slight realignment of the garage a
larger turning area an alteration to the
layout of the external parking as well
as alterations to the boundary details
as per approved under 18-03-215
vary
out in the officer's report
the application is not proposing any
alterations to the design of the
dwelling or the garage
the plumber for you is a 2018 permission
so i would draw to committee's attention
the alignment of the garage
the hedging spiritually around the
property's boundaries
and the parking and turning area
this is the application for
brought before committee
so the parking area has been extended
the garage has slightly been
moved
1.8 timber board defense and is proposed
to rear the property and slide to the
west to sorry to the um east
as well as 1.2 metre rail estate fencing
around
the boundaries here we have hedging
planted in front of the dwelling but
behind the estate fencing
1.8 million timber boarding for what is
proposed here as well which is erected
at this moment times you'll see in the
photos but hedging is also proposed
within this area
i would also draw the attention of three
teres as well as a processing in front
on the parking area
so this is the application site itself
this is dwelling which is obviously now
been built
this is down in hollywood
road
this is the estate fencing which is
reimposed on the rear which i'll show in
two seconds
front of the dwelling you can see the
timber wall defensing
this is now coming up around school lane
this is the side of the property
obviously the estate fence goes around
as per the what the proposal is hedging
would be located along this state fence
and stretching all the round
this is the area to the
along the pod road leading off school
lane this would actually be removed if
it was per the approved plans and the
state rail fencing as indicated will be
situated along here with hedging
situated to rio the garage is obviously
been erected and is retrospective in its
position
and this is looking into the property
as indicated within the port it is
acknowledged that this area would be
visible from this private road leading
off school school lane
and that is it chair in consideration in
the area's development plan national
policy and guidance as well as the
relevant statutory consultations the
officers recommendations on planning
balance approval subject to recommended
conditions
as psycho in the office's report but no
updates thank you joe thank you very
much we'll move to our first speaker on
this item here's councillor john
franklin councillor franklin if you'd
like to make your way forward
good evening and welcome
and you've probably got an understanding
of how things are going to work so
you'll have three minutes i'll give you
a 30 second warning before the end uh
but otherwise um if you press the middle
button on the microphone to turn it on
and whenever you're ready feel free to
start certainly
well first of all we'd like to thank mr
brooks for his work on the application
and
we are happy with most of the
recommendations that he's made
um we're agreed that the industrial
wooden fencing is an inappropriate
material which is why he's recommended
changes and there's not in keeping with
the surrounding environment everywhere
else in the village boundaries are
either hedges
stone or brick walls
we agreed that the original hedges
should not have been ripped out and that
they should have been replaced had they
been taken out
and i'm sure that we would agree that we
should do everything possible to protect
our natural environment that's my
background
the only area where we have a difference
of opinion with mr brooks is allowing
the retention of wooden fencing on the
sudden boundary
this fencing is clearly visible from
school lane and the corner of holly bush
lane
his view is that the retention of the
fencing causes little harm
our view is that is an eyesore is
incompatible with the surrounding
properties is out of place in a con
conservation area and should never have
been erected
we would ask the committee to insist
that hedging is reinstated
if the committee is not minded to do
this we would ask that the wooden
fencing is replaced with the estate
fencing which has been applied
everywhere else on the property
and if that fails we would ask that the
planting scheme has agreed that would
cover the offending
fencing that's the end of what i have to
say it's a very minor matter but um it's
important to us
comfortably within your three minutes so
thank you members do we have any
questions for councillor franklin
no
in that case thank you very much for
your patience and control you'll be
short if you could give the desk a quick
wipe and back your hands that would be
great
and while you're doing that i'll call
forward our next speaker who is mr matt
sharples on behalf of our applicant do
we have mr sharples here
you'd like to make your way forward
and once again i think you've probably
got an understanding of how things work
now so three minutes 30 second warning
whenever you're ready it's over to you
evening councillors i'm not sharples i'm
here tonight to support
uh our application with the variations
of condition two and five of our
planning approval
when we purchased the land from a local
resident the site was overgrown had not
been maintained for many years
when clear inside it became apparent
that the existing hedgerows had been
left to grow far beyond the point where
they could be recovered
due to this lack of care
and as mentioned in the agricultural
report undertaken by what natural
infrastructure consultants
that we'd already had commissioned
uh in relation to the original planning
condition the report categorized the
existing hedge as being see oblique two
three stroke hedges of low quality
offering low or
only temporary stroke transient
landscape benefits
it was therefore decided that uh
the vegetation was removed and in its
place
we planted uh
new hedging
consisting of native species of course
in the meantime a close boarded fence we
erected a close body fence to give the
occupants of winterberry cottage some
form of privacy
which i think we all deserve in the back
garden
uh to the rear of the garden
until obviously the new plants will
establish themselves
this new fencing was erected upon the
centerline of the original hedro
taking into account several fence posts
that were discovered
whilst the site work
was being undertaken
during this planning application process
we have worked with the case officer and
considered prize martin parish council's
comments relating to
their
view on fencing
and we've
we've suggested the removal of eight
meters of close boarded fencing
and to replace it with the 1.2 meter
high estate railings
together with more hedge planting of
native species
as previous mentioned the the fences
have been erected upon the center line
of the old hedgerow
my colleague rob wilkes grew up in prize
master living there from 1970 to 1989
his father had actually owned the piece
of land that the house is built upon
in the past and to our knowledge there
has never been an established vehicle
access
adjacent to the site either past or
present
this has also been confirmed by several
uh
residents of the village or i know
who've also lived there for many many
years
that's about it and i'd like your
support in
uh our application to approve
some fencing
with associated hedging
thank you thank you very much mrs
shaples members do we have any questions
for counsel and servant thank you
um
the hedge planting
you said that you put the
fence in at the center of where the
hedge was so wherever you planted your
hedging
the hedging's been planted
the hedges been planted at the moment
around the state railings which at the
moment run all the way around the
property adjacent highway
yeah
is that on your property yeah
but the hedge has gone on the existing
center line of the head yeah so you put
an edge out of the
line of what it was no no it's adjacent
the highway we own up to the highway
okay it might be helpful if we get the
officers to show us that uh genuine
points of clarification that's all
that's already been done
right as per
the the approve the original approval
okay we're talking about what we're
talking about see along the bottom there
yeah it's close boarded fencing around
the rear of the property yes and down
the side
we're not actually talking about all the
stuff around no no no i think i think
i'm going to stop that there we'll get
some clarification from our officers at
their appropriate time members do we
have any other questions for mr charles
no in that case thank you very much for
contribution and patience
while you're cleaning the desk for us we
will call forward councillor rock who is
our ward member and our next speaker
councillor rock good evening you know
the drill five minutes i'll give you 30
second warning use as much or little as
that five minutes as you wish
whenever you're ready feel free to start
members thank you very much can you just
make sure your microphone is on i think
you turn it off but yeah i think it was
already austin enough
something i'm often accused of well
perhaps not but um
well this has been a bit of a confusing
application
uh because it's a retrospective
application it's a variation on a
variation
and the plan officer and i've had a
series of conversations in an attempt to
clarify that
i can see where the parish council have
been
distressed about it because the original
plan which i think
the officer showed us right at the
beginning showed hedges all the way
around the application there it is
and we've ended up with
something that doesn't have that and
significant close board defenses
which the applicant has explained
well i think he was hinting that that
was a temporary arrangement however uh
again i've got simply the parish council
of the unsightly nature of that
uh however
during whatever discussions have taken
place in the office in the applicant
considerable improvements have been
wrought upon that and i think we're very
close to uh having something that's
acceptable
um
i i think uh counter henchmen surfing
that's an interesting point about the
planting but uh i think we've got to
a pretty good position as likely going
to get because most of the
boundaries that face the public spaces
and have now been approved they actually
have been planted
since uh some of the pictures were taken
and the point that
remains an issue is only the back fence
or side fence there isn't really a back
frontal side in this property it
protrudes as you can see in a sort of
peninsula
and it's it's quite a prominent site so
we're talking about the most southern
point of that now as it happens the
property has been sold during the uh the
meantime uh and i spoke to the uh
resident
who's actually not keen on the close
board defense
uh and is keen to soften the appearance
of that close board defense which you
can see joe if he got that picture
please that looks through the gateway
um
if there's a car in the way but it's
actually
from the public realm you can
see pretty much straight through there
are no gates the opening is
it's very visible and it is that visible
fence which is not shown that clearly in
there but the applicant tells me she's
quite happy to plant the uh
something to master front of that with
some sort of planting in front of that
which i think would go some way to um
meeting the uh the concerns of the
parish council indeed myself when we
started off and if we can remove these
close boarded fences along the lines
that the um officer has now agreed
through all the various negotiations and
amendments
i for myself would be content with that
so
um
joe and i spoke this afternoon if if we
could possibly put a note on that we're
expecting
some sort of softening of that that
would be
uh honor would be satisfied i think
whether we're able to do that i know or
not i don't know but i think all the
other boundaries have been met and what
i would also say is the other details
that are on there are non-controversial
and nobody's got any difficulty with it
so it's just a question of getting these
boundaries in keeping with the rest of
the village and in with the conservation
zone which i think we have 99 achieved
thank you very much chairman
thank you very much councillor rock um
casa dixon first please
nigel so that we can have an
understanding between that plan there
and the photograph that you we had a
moment ago with that car and the fence
on is that fence on the east side of
that or the south side of that because
obviously as you say it's a difficult
one to get your eyes around
yes
the picture that joe showed us is
taken actually if we go back to the plan
joe that would probably help us more
um
the picture
if you're standing there there's a big
the biggest tree you can see there
is actually been
felled there
it's looking southwest from that through
that gap that gap there straight at that
fence there and that's
the one that the parish council were
concerned about yes and so you can see
the entire run of what looks like a
zigzag fence there okay through that
i'll just point one one other point of
information the road is looking across
joe said it was a private road far bit
me to put the officers right but that is
a public highway
okay does that answer your question
thank you um council andrew serafin
asked a question about the hedge line
and planting um and how it fits in with
what was there originally could you
please explain for the benefit of all of
us
yes sure so
fundamentally
oh that's i mean it sounds like from
character rock that's on the planet
might have been put in for when i was on
site the estate rail fencing was
situated
around this area and that area there is
1.8
timber boarded fencing so to clarify
there's the aesthetic rail fencing but
as you can see i wouldn't see any heads
in there
that's a long hollywood um road
that's hollywood road still coming up
our own school lane see the state rail
fencing has been situated
that's the timber boarding fence in
which the applicant is proposing to
remove coming off school lane and then
looking into it
the estate rail fencing has been done
now for my type visit as you can see the
planting hadn't been finished but it
sounds like that might have changed very
recently
can you compare that with what it was
like
so what was previously approved heading
all the way around the boundaries
and you see that's the open access way
on school lane
and heading to the rear as well
okay thank you can senator sarah from
does that
clarify the question you had earlier
marvelous thank you very much any more
questions counselor rock
no in that case council rock thank you
very much for your help sorry i've
jumped the gun a little bit went
straight to getting fabricated there i
apologize that's my fault
now again it's clarification points for
officers council dixon
thank you chairman
on page 23 uh joe but to start at the
top it says a small section of the
timber fencing is still on the western
boundary
look
page 33
the big part based page 33 sorry small
section is still on the western boundary
further down a small section of fencing
circuit 10 meters
uh situated in front of an amenity area
etc so one i was wondering how long is
this small section on the western
boundary and did we have a photograph of
that please because
one section is referred to as 10 meters
being small and the other one is also
small without a measurement
so that's the section that's on the
western boundary which the africans
propose and put
hedging in front so this is long holy
bus road so that's if you see that's the
fencing to the rear of the boundary
which would be retained but to be fair
on this site which is along a public
realm the applicant is also proposing to
put hedging within that area so that
sense will be
that would be
probably
yes
so if i go back to the plan
that's the fence in there and that's the
fence in there from the photo i've just
shown as you can see hedging is proposed
all the way around that section
the
other side is that small section there
okay do we have any other points of
clarification from our officers
no in that case that's opening the
debate who would like to kick us off
i'm going to pick on someone councillor
dixon please
having had all that clarification i will
propose that we grant it chairman thank
you very much councillor kendall
marvelous and if anyone else wants to
contribute to the debate
no in that case we have a proposal to
grant in line with officer
recommendation could have sheriff
hansel's in favor please
that appears to be unanimous so uh
committee therefore resolves to grant
application twenty one zero one five six
five a very that is land adjacent to
holly bush cottage in prize martin
marvelous let's move on to our next
application
which is application
2101850ful as a dog lane fisheries again
prize martin road napton on the hill our
presenting officer is aaron weatherston
aaron whenever you're set and
comfortable do feel free to start
thank you chairman the application site
lies in the southeast of napton on the
hill as identified by the black dot on
this plan
just here the site lies outside of the
built-up area boundary identified within
the neighborhood plan in the countryside
site also lies within the einstein hills
special landscape area
this slide identifies the application
site outlined in red
shown just here
site comprises of a possible parcel of
land currently used the touring caravan
germany can you get erin to move but i
think a bit better is that better sorry
just a little bit
over in the far corner the hard
appearing corner
access to the site is available from the
road to the north the access is shared
with the other uses within the wider
site including the fishing lakes
touring caravan pictures and associated
facilities
public right of way sm42c crosses the
application site which is shown by pink
dash line just here
and here on this other plan
planning permission is up the erection
of a rural workers dwelling which seeks
to replace the existing log cabin on
site which is shown approximately here
the proposal will include a new access
drive from the existing internal access
road just here an associated garden
the existing planting set along the
roadside to the north and to the west
will be retained as part of the proposal
the public footpath will also be
proposed to be diverted to facilitate
the development this is shown in the
green dash line here
and here on the plan
this slide shows the proposed elevations
of the dwelling the dwelling will be two
story and finished in brick under a
slate roof the dwelling will include
living accommodation at ground floor
including a site office and have four
bedrooms at first floor
the dwelling will have a ridge height of
approximately 7.5 metres and eaves
height of 4.8 and 4.4 meters
respectively the key design features
include gables pitch roof door windows
and a porch canopy which you can see
just here on the drawings
this light is an aerial image of the
area the application site is shown
approximately in the red circle just
here
the three fishing lakes linked to the
wider business are visible within the
wider site here
here and here
the settlement of knapped on the hill is
visible to the west of the image and is
set on a higher level than the
application site just here
views are available at the site from
vicarage road and school hill
the key viewpoints are shown by the
orange areas on this slide they include
the view from the top of fells lane
which is this arrow here the view from
the granary at the top of public right
of way sm42c which is this arrow here
and the view from school hill which is
identified as an important view number
six in policy nine of the ndp which is
this arrow just here
this slide shows a photograph taken from
the top of fells lane looking towards
the application site
the arrow here shows the approximate
location of the application site
just there
this slide shows a photograph taken at
the top of the public right-of-way sm42c
adjacent to the granary looking towards
the application site again the arrow
here shows the approximate location of
the application site
this slide shows a photograph taken from
school hill looking towards the
application site the arrow here shows
the approximate location of the
application site this is identified as
important view 6
policy policy 9 of the ndp
this slide shows a photograph of the
application site from the road you can
see the access to the right of the image
here
and this photograph is taken from the
road looking back towards napton on the
hill with the application site shown on
the left hand side of the image
this slide shows a couple of photographs
of the access to the site the first
image on the left of
the slide was taken looking from the
road into the application site existing
shower block and toilet facility
building is visible to the right of the
image and the log cabin that's proposed
to be removed in the centre of the image
the photograph to the right of this
slide was taken from the existing hard
standing area looking towards the
application site see the existing
screening here cafe cited here and the
access through to the application site
just here on the right hand side
this final slide shows a photograph
taken from the internal access road
looking back towards the application
site sighting
this is the access from the cafe area
down here public right of way cross is
approximately here as proposed and this
is the boundary treatment to the the
road here along the north of the site
and to the west of the site for a number
of updates for this application which
have been shown on the update sheet it's
recommended that planning permission be
granted for the reason split out in the
opposite report thank you
erin thank you very much we will call
forward our first speaker who is
councillor richard woodcock from napton
parish council good evening councillor
so once again you'll have three minutes
i'll give you 30 second warning whenever
you're settled please feel free to start
can you hear me
okay okay i'll commence thank you i'm
richard woodcock i'm the chairman of
nupton parish council and i'm here to
object to this new dwelling application
at napton fisheries
the stratfor district council core
strategy protects against new dwellings
being built built in open countryside
and this application falls well outside
the napton built up area boundary there
are of course exceptions such as rural
agricultural workers dwellings which is
the case in this instance
knapton parish council are not against
the concept of a rural agricultural
workers dwelling on this site in fact we
have supported two previous applications
on this same site
we do however feel that we must object
to this latest application as we believe
that it is too large and to austere and
will be in contrary to our recently
ratified neighborhood development plan
we believe that the building itself is
far larger than is required to support
the dog lane fisheries business compared
to the more modest applications
previously granted
the location of the site in question
falls directly in the line of sight
between important view number sorry
important view and vista number five
looking across the valley in towards the
village from the shupbrigated road and
also important view and vista number six
looking across the valley and onto
shukra woods from the public bench on
school hill
the deciduous leaved foliage currently
in place gives a deceptive impression of
screening
much of this will need to be removed to
build the dwelling proposed and during
winter months in particular the dwelling
will be a blot on the scenic ambience
currently enjoyed and protected
furthermore the design of the building
in question is also odds with a special
landscape and iron stone fringe in so
much that it contravenes the character
assessment also contained within the
neighborhood development plan
and would be more suited to an urban
setting
we ask that the planning committee
reject the current application and
encourage the applicants to consider a
more modest dwelling which we could then
support thank you council thank you very
much members do we have any questions
for our counsellor
no in that case thank you very much for
your contribution and you've already
beat me to it
while you're doing that i will call
forward our next speaker who is joshua
whitehead our applicant
good evening and welcome thank you for
your patience um i think you've got a
grasp of things now so three minutes 30
second warning and if you could stay on
for questions afterwards that'd be great
otherwise over to you
the application for a permanent rural
workers dwelling had previously been
approved by the council the permission
had lapsed due to in maine the death of
my grandfather and probate being sorted
whilst this was being addressed the
council permitted a retention of a
desisting temporary dwelling for two
years
it should be noted that the plans
approved by the council for the rural
workers dwelling was for a two-story
three-bedroom dwelling
log cabin with an internal floor area of
156 metres
the current application before the
council is for a two-story four-bedroom
rural workers dwelling including an
office with an internal floor area of
160 metres
the council's agricultural consultant
kerman
countryside consultants
are supportive of the permanent rural
workers dwelling
they confirm that there is an
established essential need for a rural
worker myself and family to live on site
they confirm that the business is
sustainable and profitable now and in
the long term
this has been accepted by the council
proposed writing of the dwelling is
accessed from the car park which has an
existing access
the proposed dwelling is located behind
a high hedge so no new access is closed
the proposed sighting will substantially
reduce any health and safety issues with
my family
and minimize any contact with vehicular
movements into and out of the premises
this was an important consideration with
the reciting of the dwelling
the previous
and previously approved dwelling
it is an important factor with any rural
workers dwelling and vehicle in
movements
there is existing well useful footpath
albeit not the original one that has
been used by ramblers for many years
indeed during this period of my
grandfather
running the business
this footpath has permanent entrances
and exits of prize martin road and dog
lane
this well-used footpath lies outside the
cartilage of the proposed new rule
workers dwelling
the council is supportive of my planning
application and i trust that the
committee will endorse my planning
application thank you very much well
within your time members do we have any
questions for mr whitehead please
counselor dixon
i will make one if i may um
but we obviously heard from the parish
council that they thought that the
design was
urban
obviously look into our report
the local vernacular in actuator is
brick and tile which is what you're
proposing
um i just wondered what your views are
on that comment as to whether or not
timber cladding or anything else like
that might be more suitable in a country
file open area
i mean if necessary we could amend the
plan if that was needed but obviously
looking at knapton
there isn't two houses the same in
napton
and obviously of all the recent
buildings
the design that's been made matches any
recent thing so red brick tile roof
like this
thank you very much i'll just remind you
that we we do have to decide or make a
decision on what's in front of us now on
amended plan so that was directed at our
councillors rather than yourself
anyone else have a question they would
like to ask mr whitehead
no in that case thank you very much for
your patience and contribution
you've already beaten me to it marvelous
while you're doing that i shall call
forward our next speakers cancel rock
again cancel rock if you'd like to make
your way forward
and once again you'll have five minutes
with a 30 second warning and stay on for
questions otherwise whenever you're
settled and ready to go
thank you very much mr chairman um i
wonder if the officer could show us the
slide of policy map three with the
arrows on
it's page 71 of the
mobile development plan you put it up
earlier erin
while you're doing that i'll start
um a bit like
the previous application on which i
spoke um
that there are just one specific point
uh in this uh application there's no
dispute about the need for an
agriculturally related dwelling at the
application at the location
scale and the design are the issue and
that's solely because of the potential
impact on the landscape
over many years and virtually every
application on this site the sensitivity
has been picked up by planning
inspectors the parish council the ward
members and the previous
now virtually expired parish plan it's
now 10 years old
in the case of the parish plan limited
weight could be attached to that
protection of views but now we have the
neighborhood development plan
made and adopted only in july of this
year
which has full weight and is part of the
core strategy
as has been pointed out the site lies
directly in line with two protected
blues in the enabled development plan
numbers five and six on the plan
a previous application for an
agricultural dwelling has now elapsed
that one was passed before the enabled
development plan
and might be considered marginal in its
size and its impact against the naval
development plan but at least that one
was in keeping it was one and a half
story construction
and it was of a timber appearance and it
fitted in with the
sort of scope of where it is in the
fishing lakes it's not in the middle of
the village
it is in a
very much a rural location next to the
fishing lanes which i have to say are
very nicely kept
i'd like to read you the relevant
policies in the knapped enabled
development plan
made and adopted a few weeks ago
policy one
proposals for residential development
will be supported providing all of the
following are met
the development is of small scale
it has regard to the character
assessment in terms of scale layer and
materials and retains local
distinctiveness to create a sense of
place
it protects and enhances public rights
of way
all of these are breached by this
application
policy nine of the ndp lists the
important and protected views which are
shown on this policy map and the site
lies directly in between views and six
policy 10 states that development will
only be supported if the appearance of
the area in terms of its historic and
vernacular built form does not cause
demonstrable harm
policy 11 states the development should
retain and protect mature trees woodland
and headphones could we show that
picture from the car park please sir
erin with uh
looking towards the
snack bar
um
what this and there's also one from the
caravan uh
view from from this that one there
uh
the site plan uh in the application
shows a rather urban design of house
nestled inside that wooded area
in practice this plot is currently
occupied deciduous trees most of which
were required to be felt
all the pictures that had taken in all
the views and so on shows
trees and hedges in full leap after the
biggest growing season this year
after autumn and in the winter of spring
the visual intrusion of the house will
be impossible to mitigate
unless undesirable non-native evergreen
species such as fast-growing conifers
are planted which i'm sure none of us
would want
they would take many years to cover a
house with a 7.57 metre high ridge which
is replacing the two-bedroom log cabin
of 3.43 meters in height
in summary i'm sure that the officers
have considered many of these points
but my judgment is different to theirs
we ask the community to do these
neighborhood plans there's an awful lot
of effort goes into them and this one's
only just been made
are we just going to ignore it we must
respect them
the property is just too big and out of
context now then a smaller dwelling with
a low ridge height that can be readily
masked by native planting and one that
does not require the diversion of a
public footpath
that would be unlikely to receive
objection and indeed i believe it would
get support
in the event that the committee's minded
to approve the application contrary to
my was for a better scheme i would ask
that a legal agreement is used to insist
upon proper landscaping because the
planning enforcement of this history of
the site suggests a degree of difficulty
for the authority and in
ensuring conformance thank you very much
for your time
thank you council iraq members do you
have any questions for cancer up please
no in that case council rock thank you
for your patience thank you very much we
all now move to points clarification to
offices does anyone have any question
they would like to ask our officers
councillor jennings
thank you i wondered if i could see the
photos again from viewpoint five and six
because i'm and i appreciate it's the
summer but i'm struggling to see
the fishing lakes or the existing
buildings from nearly's
points
this one just here is from view um
sticks of the ndp you bear with me i'll
just find you the other one we do have
another photograph from the other
viewpoints
okay
so this is the viewpoint from viewpoint
five um from the campsite at the top you
can see the arrow is the approximate
location of the application site with
napton in the background just here i do
have the photographs from the ndp if
that would be helpful the ones that are
in the the actual documents
i think that's supposed to be honest
okay thank you that can't change can you
turn your microphone off for me please
thank you did i see a hand go up on my
left hand side then
at the corner of my eye no no other
points clarification
in that case let's move to debate who
wants kicks off counselor jennings
please
okay well
the rural workers dwellings are
obviously very important in these rural
these rural businesses because of we're
all crime and i actually understand why
everyone seems to be in favor of this
um
i don't feel that the
proposed property is particularly large
so could be viewed as small scale
um
obviously part of the building is going
to be used for the work or office
so that takes out a particular chunk of
the house um
if you're not going to go up you've got
to go wide
to accommodate everything
um
i'm happy to support an existing
business
um they've
volunteered permitted developments are
taken away
i'm quite happy to um
propose that we go along with officers
recommendations and grant on this
planning application
thank you very much cancer journalists
cancer kendall please
thank you very much council dixon first
please
thank you chairman um i won't be
actually supporting the officer's
recommendation on this one
i can recall i think a training session
not that long ago where we were advised
that design is now a very important
aspect of all applications and that we
should be aiming to improve the public
realm now i'm not looking at the views
from napton and the ndp etc i'm thinking
about the use of that public right of
way whereby that property if constructed
in those con those materials
will be
out of place it belongs in an urban
environment and essentially if the
design not too concerned regarding the
volume because i think the volume etc is
probably
affordable and reasonable
but i think the outside appearance of
that property is too urban for me to
support thank you chairman okay council
crump next please
it must be the grumpy corner over here
because i don't agree with that
counselor dixon um i i've got issues
regarding the size and scale a little
bit
the design obviously again i think is
more suited to an urban rather than
rural setting
uh and asks the um
the the upton mdp uh various policies
there which is contrary to which this
building is contrary to um
so therefore i won't be supporting this
um application
i definitely agree with the need that
the greed is not in question but i don't
think it's quite right for the for the
uh location um and its size and and
obviously the special landscape so
i will not be supporting the officer's
recommendation thank you mr crump cancer
hence your seraphim next bill good chair
um
the design
is not desirable in the location uh the
previous application design
looks more in keeping the countryside so
i will not be supporting this
application
purely on design
understood thank you very much cancer
jennings for one last go
just want to say design is a subjective
matter
and that's
always down to the individual
council fleming next please
uh i'd just like to say that uh
that we should do our best to be
supporting these local businesses
um it's a rural business in a rural
location
maybe the house isn't the best to design
but i don't think it it's going to cause
major harm and so i'll be supporting the
officer's recommendation thank you
fleming councillor foreman please
i would agree with what councillor
fleming's just said i think the house
could have been better designed for the
location but we do need to support rural
businesses so i will be supporting the
application
i think i'd agree with that counselor
kendall almost also said the same thing
that yes the previous application may
well have been nicer but that's not what
is in front of us now so we have to make
a decision on what is in front of us now
councilor crump you uh you very nearly
came in before councillor fleming did
you have something else you wanted to
say or should we move on
no we'll move on marvelous okay in that
case we have a proposal to grant that
has been seconded
proposed by casa jennings seconded by
cancer kendall in line with his officer
recommendation could i please have a
show of hands for those in favor
and those against
therefore committee resolves to grant
application twenty one zero one eight
five zero full that is dog lane
fisheries and nuts and on the hill now
members we've been going for an hour and
a half um i'm gonna propose a one minute
comfort break it is only going to be one
minute so please don't run off
forever
okay ladies and gents everyone if we
could please take our seats so we can
reconvene
sorry to interrupt the conversations
okay we are all back and set to go um
our committee service officer will be
back momentarily she's just sorting some
bits out for us so let's get on with the
meeting so our next item and finalizing
the evening is application number
2102078
ful that is milk house in kings cotton
our presenting officer is ellie wrench
eddie whenever you're ready over to you
thank you chair
just bring it up now
sorry i didn't have the um speaker on
that i'll start again uh removal of
storage building and breaking up and
removal of concrete slab to facilitate
construction of a detached dorma
bungalow and garage along with all other
associated works and including a change
of use of land
from the storage of caravans to
residential use with a wild flower
meadow
requiring diversion of footpath al-58
the application site is located near to
the village of king's
coton
just to the north of ulster as denoted
here by the black dot
the site is currently utilized as a
storage area for caravans and has public
right-of-way al-58 running through it as
seen here by the green line through the
site
the grade two listed milhouse is just to
the east as shown in red
and there is a neighboring bungalow to
the west
just
here
this is the proposed site layout with a
dwelling garage to the northern half of
the site and the southern half given
over to a new wildflower meadow
these are the proposed elevations of the
dwelling and garage
these are the floor plans with the
dwelling having two first floor bedrooms
on the left here is a picture of the
looking into the site with the caravans
positioned on site
also on the right hand side is the
entrance for the public right of way
through the site
this is a view looking eastwards towards
the site on the left
on the right is the
only existing building on site which is
a storage building
for the caravan use of the site
here is a picture of the neighboring
dwelling which is a bungalow
and also on the right hand side is a
view with the site on the right hand
side and the listed mill house on the
left
as well as the entrance into the
industrial unit
site
uh chair updates include further details
of the relationship of the dwelling to
the existing neighbor and amendment to
the table on existing and proposed
calculations chair the recommendation is
to refuse the application for the three
reasons detailed on page 65 of the
agenda thank you
eddie thank you very much um our first
speaker on this item is counselor clive
neal councillor if you'd like to make
your way forward
good evening welcome and thank you for
your patience
i know we've seen you here before so
you'll know the drill three minutes 30
seconds uh whenever you're free to
whenever you're ready feel free to start
thank you chairman good evening members
um my name is actually clive neil
sturgis
so
just to clarify that um i'm a current
member of the atc planning committee a
former chairman for six years
and founder chairman of the neighborhood
development plan group
the ulster ndp which was adopted this
year reflects how we the council want to
see the area developed
and we consider this development does
not harm that vision
the council's main thrust in supporting
this application is to secure future
employment in allstar
the applicant tony turner will address
you shortly he is a well-known all-star
entrepreneur who owns the industrial
estate in the application he's a major
employer in the town and is hoping to
expand
we've discussed the application on two
occasions
and one is acknowledge that there are
planning considerations we believe that
these are minor and subservient to our
support of the application to secure
future employment
we have
the committee the comments by the
officer with respect to policy as 10 and
largely is relevant as a security issue
is there's a misunderstanding here about
the use of the word security the
security issues referred to
in the applicant
in the application not material
and the policy specifically states the
future sustainability of the
enterprise
will be taken into consideration
this is our main point the third
paragraph of the officer's report again
misunderstands the issue of security on
the site
and linking it to the existing dwellings
is again irrelevant
the comments relating to cs22 and ec4
state the change of use will be resisted
unless it
unless it is no longer viable or
appropriate for a business purpose
the site is currently used as caravan
storage for local business which is in
the process of relocating
the officers comments on the green belt
are again largely incorrect as the
caravans stand on a concrete plinth
which is of itself in our view a
detriment to the green belt
and a good quality dwelling will
in our opinion
be a marked improvement on what now
exists
these are our concerns with a report and
we continue to strongly support the
application thank you chair thank you
very much councillor members do we have
any questions cancer dixon first
council you mentioned that you're
supporting this because of employment
opportunities
can you elaborate please because
obviously this is a residential or
proposal for a residential uh dorm of
angler
certainly chairman um i'm sure tony
turner will elaborate on this point
better than i can but
he is in the process of retiring
and wishes to
ensure the
continued success of his business which
is very successful
um
by building this dwelling
to house his daughter who is going to be
the new ceo
of the business
so it's turning the
concrete plinth with the caravans on
into a a good quality dwelling
with an
a a wildflower meadow around it etc and
in our view it would be a lot better
than what exists at present
we'll determine that in your course
thank you
council from you i think your question's
been asked
anyone else have any questions for
cancer neil sturgis please
no in that case thank you very much for
your patience and contribution this
evening
while you're wiping down the desk i will
call forward on next speaker who is uh
mr tony turner himself and of course we
have uh the agent liz nicholson as well
if you'd like to make your way forward
pick a desk
i can't open it i should no no
liz i don't know if you want to give
that okay
yourself
oh it's there
sorry it's open sherman
how many counselors does it take to open
an open packet
thank you very much councillor
okay so we've got you both listed to
speak are you splitting the time or is
it no mr turner's going to speak and i'm
just here if there's any questions we'll
we'll answer those no problem at all so
mr turner you'll have three minutes with
30 second warning whenever you're ready
feel free to start thank you very much
mr chairman and thank you good evening
ladies and gentlemen
in 1963 i set up the first turner
company at king's coat and mill
manufacturing flail mowers to cut
roadside verges and hedges
by 1989 it was employing 160 locally
they are still being made locally at the
alamo company at salford priors
green mech was established in 1993 to
design and manufacture a range of
british wood chippers and green waste
treaders
it has become a leading manufacturer in
europe employing 110 skilled and
semi-skilled staff
plus a further 20 or so in local
subcontracting companies
currently we have a massive order book
providing we get approval to expand our
production facilities we expect to
increase our local label force to about
135 plus the subcontractors
we have two very successful sales and
support companies in germany and france
the french company is operated by my
grandson and his sister overseen by my
daughter
very much a family affair
eighty percent of our production is
exported we've also been awarded two
queens awards for export and innovation
turner r d owns the industrial estate
and 26 acres along almost a kilometer of
the river arrow
the area is being rewilded
the environment agency river authority
and warwickshire wildlife trust are
advising on this exciting project
it will include a hundred plus
indigenous trees and wildflower meadows
creating a park-like setting
including a flock of sheep and other
farm
animals
areas alongside the river are being
adopted by local schools to educate
children in countryside matters
my own background is in farming and
agricultural engineering
i'm now 87 my children own a third each
of both companies
cheryl in france is company secretary of
both jonathan is managing director of
greenmech rebecca trained as an
occupational therapist
the first four cottages at the mill and
the two lodges
provide affordable accommodation for
tenants and employees on the estate
i wish we had more
we need a new modest house for rebecca
and her family
built on the estate to manage the
industrial area
the animals and increased activity on
the 26 acre parkland
leaving me as long as i am able to
continue my passion developing new
products
and ensuring the business continues to
prosper and remains under family control
for future generations living up to uh
motto engineering for a greener
environment thank you
mr thank you very much members do we
have any questions for either mr turner
or for his agent
council jennings
um
say a modest house
266 square meters
do you describe us
i think it is quite modest yes
two bit fun
the two bedrooms yes
i like
quite thank you i
i think you've answered this question
and members any other questions
counselor cramp
mr turner i think you're looking
remarkably well for
so uh
stop flirting and ask a question no no
i'm not just impressed
if i ever got to 87 you'd look like well
i'll be uh i'll be very impressed thank
you
hard work and
so you're saying this is basically um
for your daughter and she's an integral
integral part of your business uh growth
business development and that's the
ideal location for your or your business
yes we need we need she's um
managing the estate itself including the
the 26 acres that we're rewiring
and actually
you know we have animals in that as well
and we really do need her on the estate
thanks very much
cancer fleming please
mr turner um
in the
recommendation that we've got
it says
that uh building this house can lead to
a lot of employment um you've just been
saying a few minutes ago that
that you intend for more employees on
this site
i
can't work out why
the office is saying there's going to be
a lot of employment and you tell us
there's going to be more people
uh thank you i'll pick that one up
i think what the officers are talking
about is the loss of the caravan storage
site and there is no employment there it
was
it was run by mr turner's wife when she
was still alive you know it's a few
hours a month probably and mr turner's
followed that on
um
there are no employees your appeal
decision recently in bidford should
remind you that if there isn't
employment there it's not an existing
employment site and your policy
therefore isn't really relevant
the caravan will disappear i'm assuming
when broad lane moved to their new
premises no it's not related to to broad
lane i mean this is a private operation
that's been going on for 40 odd years
okay thank you
okay do we have any other questions
members
no
in that case both you thank you very
much for your contributions this evening
thank you
okay so our final speaker of the evening
is councillor cargill councillor cargill
if you'd like to make your way forward
and again you know how this works so
five minutes 30 second warning when
you're set and settled feel free to
start i've never been here before in my
life
thank you very much indeed
members
right um
off to town council have already stated
that this application does not in their
view harm their vision of the ndp and
the as-10 is not applicable in this
application
discussion revolves around building a
modest dwelling on a previously
developed land i will turn to the
principle development first
in correspondence to the applicant the
officer says that i consider dwelling of
reduced scale would result in a reduced
cumulative impact of openness which may
overcome greenbelt concerns and remove
this as a reason for refusal this is
repeated in the pre-application advice
uh not noted in the offices report
where it suggests a small single story
drawing may be appropriate for the site
with materials similar to those used in
the immediate vicinity i consider that
tacit approval for dwelling in this
location
the report identifies in 17-02031
granted permission for two workers
dwellings which currently house
employees and affordable accommodation
on site
i believe that's unreasonable to link
the two dwellings to the function of
site security and we've mentioned that
i'll come to security in a moment those
dwellings are for workers in the factory
and need identified then and even more
important now
as mentioned the ultimate goal is a
long-term survival prosperity and
security of the company which benefits
the local community
the officer comments that having a
director in close proximity to the
business is clearly beneficial to the
business and the family i agree the
director will not only be responsible
for the security and viability of the
factory and the site but also the wider
management of the estate the applicant
has a grand vision for this area but it
will need management
the opportunities for natural landscape
rewiring and the educational
opportunities it presents are
significant
regarding the caravan storage site which
is confusing i agree i feel it's
stretching reason to suggest that this
is an employment site
the officer says that the site is
currently in economic use the business
was run solely by mr cena's wife who
suddenly passed away last year
it could not there for be easily
transferred even if the owner wished to
do so
the caravans cannot be described as
temporary as although they can be moved
others can also fill that space vacated
up to 30 caravans have been stored there
for over 20 years and therefore it can
be accurate described as permanent
storage
the lawful development certificate for
that area only allows for caravan
storage limiting further economic use
moving back to greenbelt concerns
i am as you know from a couple of weeks
ago here a passionate supporter of
greenbelt and vigorously defend it
however in this case in my opinion the
impact will be less than substantial the
officer's report notes that cs10
supports a partial or complete
redevelopment of a previously developed
brownfield site whether redundant or in
continuing use subject to it not having
a materially greater impact on the
openness of the green belt
the proposal is remove up to 30 caravans
a large concrete slab tin shed and other
debris which can only be betterment to
the area the proposed development is
effectively hidden from view just not on
the main road or in full visibility
the relocation of the public footpath is
another betterment allowing improved
access into the countryside and in
conjunction with the grand scheme that's
being proposed
in summary members you have the support
from the town council my support no
objections tested agreement for a
dwelling on this site no identifiable
harm to the greenbelt no loss of
employment no sustainability issues
reuse of brownfield land betterment to
the site significant landscape
improvements rewilding educational
opportunities and importantly the
potential to help secure an established
rural business process businesses
prosperity into what could be an
exciting future for it
members i hope you all agree with me
this is about planning balance and i
believe that the proposed improvements
outweigh any harm that has been
identified thank you members
thank you council cargill members to
have any questions for council cargill
please cancel crump first
i won't be making similar comments here
i decided to uh mr turner about looking
good
no seriously
good to see you here today he's only 27.
yeah it's just a very quick question um
will there be improved community access
to the site i know you mentioned
education and i think it was um the
schools as well i just wondered about
community access really to the site
that is the proposal part of the
proposal it will become a parkland area
now i should also say that some areas
alongside the river arrow have also been
allocated to schools in the area for
educational facilities as well as
general access through the public
footpath
thank you
council fleming please
uh
cancer cargo is is this likely to
how visible is it going to be from the
main road i mean you know i mean we draw
drive along the 435 but
i'm guessing that it's not going to be
particularly visible from the main road
not visible at all
i suspected that but i just it's a long
time to have been down that lane but
that's
okay thank you
any more questions for cancer cargill
please
no in that case council cargill thank
you for your patience and your time this
evening
okay members let's move into points of
clarification to our officers does
anyone have a question that they would
like to raise councillor jennings first
please
um just wanted to clarify
is this brown belt that's a brownfield
or green belt
it is part brownfield so the building
and hard standing would be considered
brownfield it's a mixture
anyone else have a question they'd like
to ask councillor dixon please
thank you chairman eddie um
councillor cargill made reference to
pre-application advice
um have you possibly found some of that
and just wondered if you could uh
fill us in with what that actually was
please
chairman um
i have to say
that did concern me a little bit um
[Music]
it sounds to me
a little bit like a slippery slope um
are we if members go down that slippery
slope are they accepting that when
officers have
given advice that an application is
acceptable that this committee are going
to go along with that advice at some
later date of course they're not
the members are going to make their own
decision based on the merits of the
application
so whatever advice the officer gave
it's for you to make a decision on the
basis of the report in front of you and
the application in front of you not on
on some
non-existent application that an officer
may or may not have given advice on
anyone else have a question before i
dive in with one
okay um eddie we've heard a lot about
the potential future employment and
how the site may well be built out in
the future um
i'm not clear that that makes up part of
this application am i right in thinking
this is solely a new
rural or sorry agricultural workers
dwelling all the periphery is not
enshrined within this application is
that right
uh that's right this is purely for an
open market dwelling so it's um it
wouldn't it's not an agricultural
workers dwelling or anything like that
is purely for a dwelling and it is just
for
the new house and the wildflower meadow
so it isn't linked to the business in
any way and the proposals don't include
any further access onto land or anything
that might come forward in the future i
think if i can go beyond that chair i
don't think the applicant's even begun
to demonstrate that the existing six
dwellings on site
can't provide adequate supervision or
security or management for the the
business they may not be appropriate for
a director of the business but it's not
essential for a director of the business
to live on site if they have staff who
can perform all of these other functions
and obviously directors come to work
during the working day like normal
people
thank you forgive me for saying it was
an agricultural dwelling i was getting
confused another application um so on
that basis we haven't conducted any form
of um
uh consultation or or anything in terms
of the need um if if we were minded to
go along the agricultural route
and no it hasn't been assessed in that
function but i think as part of some of
the very special circumstances they put
certain business cases forward but not
as an actual uh dwelling tied to the um
business
okay you've dealt with the circumstances
that were put forward in your report so
i'm happy with that
okay if no anyone else has no further
questions for our officer we'll move
into the debate who would like to kick
us off
who am i gonna pick on first councillor
kendall
that would be very helpful thank you
very much um would anyone else like to
contribute to the debate at this point
councillor crump point them um
yeah i i
i sympathize totally where
counts the candles i think according to
danny then sorry a councillor kendall
was coming from there you know i've got
a lot of sympathy with this application
um but yeah i'm trying i was really
trying to support this as much as i can
so i think it's it's a great asset for
the community uh supported by the town
council and supported by the ward member
um
and i think it has got the merits but
it's it's just not quite right
i think it
if it came back slightly modified with a
strengthened link to the business
to demonstrate that need
you know i would certainly support it
then but it's just not quite right and
i'm concerned
that we might be setting a president um
yeah it pains me to say this you know i
would really like to support this
application but
the brain the heart no the head is rule
in the heart on this occasion i'm afraid
and i do this with the with the heavy
hearts trying to use makes me metaphors
that i'm afraid um but i i would be
willing to support cancer kendall's
needy cancer danny again sorry the
councillor kendra's the
proposal
it's been a long day so
it sounds like it came over scrutiny
this morning that okay and then that's
uh
okay so we've got a proposal um we've
got it seconded does anyone else want to
contribute to the debates before we move
to a vote
no in that case the proposal in front of
us is to refuse uh planning in uh in
line with the officer's recommendation
could i please have a show of hands
those in favor of refusal
and those against
one in that case committee resolves to
refuse application twenty one zero two
zero seven eight ful as mill house in
kings cotton um members there is no
urgent business
so it leaves me to thank all of our
speakers all of you all of our officers
but in particular eddie wrench for whom
this is his last presentation to us um
eddie thank you very much for
all of your detailed reports your very
eloquent uh presentations so thank you
and good luck with with your future we
will close the meeting there thank you
everyone
you